- So this will be a very different talk
than the last one we heard.
So like a lot of philosophers,
I'm interested in very general questions
and this is a question
that I've pursued in very different ways,
"What are the nature, scope and limits
of knowledge in physics?"
And other philosophers
of science have looked
at other fields of course.
I've just by chance ended up
and by interest, working
primarily on physics.
And really, I've been looking a lot
at trying to understand
what's going on in physics
in order to answer these sorts
of epistemological questions.
I've often pursued
historical case studies,
looking at the detailed development-
- [Audience Member 1] Microphone please.
- Oh, sorry,
looking at the detailed
development of particular fields
as a way to try to address this question.
But today, I wanna talk
about a different question,
focusing on a type of sciences,
or a kind of approach
to scientific projects
that I'll loosely call
historical sciences.
And so this, actually,
I should credit a former PhD
student of mine, Craig Fox,
who worked on this for a
thesis a few years ago.
So it was really working with him
that got me interested in these questions.
And also, of course, it's
relevant to cosmology,
which is something I've
thought a lot about.
And it turns out that there's
a small group of people
within philosophy of science,
who've been looking at
this question as well.
So I think a shared theme
of discussions of
historical sciences is that,
and this is not surprising
that a lot of the reasoning
in historical sciences,
is reconstructing history based on traces
that we have in the present.
And the question is how
much can we do with that?
So I think there was for a
while, a sort of crude assumption
that the historical
sciences were worse off,
compared to experimental sciences.
And that you'd face a kind
of under-determination threat
in historical sciences.
There are different ways
of expressing this worry.
One is just that you would
have a sort of decay,
or loss of information over time,
so that the traces of
past events will be harder
to access later.
And also just the obvious fact
that we don't have the ability
to manipulate historical systems
in the way that we often are able
to manipulate experimental systems.
So there's a variety of people,
who have classified as pessimists.
Sober is more complicated.
He's optimistic about some things
and has some more pessimistic
arguments as well.
Derek Turner had the misfortune
of doing what philosophers often do,
which is announce that certain
things will be impossible.
So he, as a side note in a paper, said,
"Well, there are some
things we'll never know
about the past,
such as the color of dinosaurs."
(audience member laughing)
Like a lot of philosophical
pronouncements of that sort,
that was like a prelude
to conquest by science.
So a few years later,
paleontologists gathered evidence
that seems to give them good grounds
for establishing what the
color of dinosaurs are.
So I think these are real concerns
and I think one of the
overall questions I often ask
in trying to address the big question,
is what are the evidential
challenges that a field faces?
And how have scientists
overcome those challenges
and to what extent have they done so?
The more recent literature
on historical sciences,
and here, Adrian Curry's
book is a good example,
you can see just in the
subtitle of the book,
it's "An Optimist's Guide
to the Historical Sciences".
And so he's really defending the claim
that historical sciences have
been able to establish results
with as much certainty as we
have in other areas of science.
And some of this work has focused
on case studies of specific
examples of historical sciences
that seem to have delivered
really firm results
and knowledge of the past.
There's one kind of argument
that, Carol Cleland in particular
in a 2001 paper, argued
that we can address the pessimist worry
by appealing to an asymmetry
of over-determination
that effects overdetermine causes.
And so there's a way
of thinking about this
that she's borrowing from
the Philosopher David Lewis
and his analysis of the
asymmetry of causation.
And I think although I'm much
more on the optimist side,
I find that way of framing the discussion
to be a bit limiting
and partly there's things
that I'll leave offstage,
just it's partly criticisms
of Lewis' analysis
of counterfactual asymmetry.
But what I'd like to do today,
is to suggest a different
way of framing the discussion
that's based on some of the causation
and especially the interventionist
approach to causation
that I've been dipping into recently.
So this was an invitation
that came at a good time,
because I've just started looking at this
and so it's great to have benefited
from the talks yesterday.
And you'll see that there's
a lot of common themes.
So the way I think that it's possible
to pose the question slightly differently,
is to say "What does the
world have to be like
to enable reliable
reconstructions of the deep past,"
in so far as we have been able
to succeed in giving those.
And I'm gonna focus just on two aspects
of this question here.
So there's a phrase I think
is originally Jim Woodward's,
but it's in the title
of a paper by Naftali
and Jim and Porter Williams,
a really recent paper
that says,
the question is what's the
worldly infrastructure?
So what has to be present in the world
to underwrite our ability
to make causal inferences?
And so I think there's
some very similar features
that are important for
understanding causal inferences
in the deep past.
And so I should say also
I think it's important
that these are causal inferences.
Because I think the scientists,
who are investigating the deep past,
are not just interested in
establishing what happened.
They're also interested
in establishing causal
accounts of what happened.
So I think it is crucial
that it's a causal inference
and not just a reconstruction effort.
And the other point I'll make,
so I think the methodology
of trace-based reasoning
and reconstructions based on traces,
is certainly substantially correct.
But I think there's
actually a stronger notion.
There are some cases, which
I'll call time capsules,
and it might be more a difference
of degree than of kind,
but there are some kinds of systems
that allow us to make
astonishingly good inferences
about past states.
And so I'm going to argue
that the feature of the world
that allows for those
kinds of time capsules,
is a kind of decoupling
that's been mentioned in a
few earlier talks already.
So those are the two things
I'm going to focus on,
the features that I think
the world has to have
in order to underwrite
reconstructions of the deep past.
So let me start by just,
I'll first talk about this,
the relevant notion of independence
before going back to
decoupling and traces.
And then I'll very briefly comment
on early universe cosmology.
So I'm gonna use an example here briefly
to illustrate the importance
of a notion of independence
of the initial conditions.
So this goes back to the 19th century
when Ludwig Boltzmann derived
what he called the H-theorem.
So the image across the top is meant
to be something like an
ideal gas interacting
where it's just paralyzed interactions
between the gas molecules
bouncing off of each other.
And this is meant to be a time series
where you can see the,
and if you look at the red,
you can see, well, the red
dots move in such a way
that you could imagine
that they've interacted
with the nearby particles
and have bounced off of them.
Now the striking thing
that Boltzmann derived,
is that he argued that
there's an evolution
towards an equilibrium state,
namely a particular distribution
of velocities in the gas,
called the Maxwellian
Velocity Distribution.
But as various people soon pointed out,
that was incredibly puzzling.
Because the dynamics
describing these collisions,
the pairwise collisions
between the molecules,
were completely time-reversal invariant.
So how could you get a monotonic evolution
towards equilibrium
when you have time-reversal
invariant dynamics?
And the source of the
asymmetry was an assumption
that might've seemed innocent,
which he called the (indistinct),
which we usually call molecular chaos,
which is that the interacting particles
before they collide,
their states, their velocities
and positions are independent
of one another.
They're not correlated.
But of course, that's a
time-asymmetric assumption.
If you have the two particles collide,
afterwards,
their velocities and
positions will be correlated
with one another.
And so by initially setting
those correlations aside,
you're introducing a subtle sort
of time-asymmetric initial condition.
And you can think
about how you could set up an
anti-thermodynamic evolution,
namely an ideal gas that
doesn't go towards equilibrium,
doesn't go towards the
Maxwellian Velocity Distribution.
So this is the way to set it up.
Consider any system that
evolves towards equilibrium.
Now imagine that you can
reverse all of the velocities
of the particles
and the micro-state that
you've defined in this way
under the dynamics,
there's an allowed evolution
that goes exactly the
opposite of the evolution
that just got you into the state.
And so that final micro-state
will then evolve away
from equilibrium.
But there's some really surprising
things about this, right?
The first is that what you're doing,
is taking all the correlations
that exist in that final state
and you're using the dynamics
to sort of unwind those
to take you back towards
the initial state.
And so it's an
anti-thermodynamic evolution
in the sense that this is not the kind
of thing we see everyday gases doing,
it's against all of the
features we see the evolution
towards equilibrium.
But the thing I wanna focus on,
is just that there are really two features
of this anti-thermodynamic
evolution that we can think of
in terms of the independence of the state.
So first of all,
when I've defined the state this way,
I've defined a state
that has a huge number of
complicated correlations
between the states of
the particles, right?
That's how I've introduced it.
And that's essential to have
those correlations present
in order to be able to determine
that dynamical trajectory.
There's a second point, which
is a little more subtle,
is it's also the case that
the reverse state is dependent
on the dynamics that I've used
to describe the evolution of the gas.
If I had slightly different dynamics,
that abnormal state,
even though it's got all the correlations,
wouldn't evolve
anti-thermodynamically, right?
So it's both, the state
has in the specification
of the particles,
they're all very delicately
dependent on each other.
And exactly what state it is that leads
to the anti-thermodynamic evolution,
depends on the knowledge of the dynamics
of that system as well.
And I should say, I have
various references here,
very little of what I'm
saying now is original at all.
It's just setting up a point,
or maybe nothing I'm saying
at this point is original.
Now I think there's a number
of similar kinds of
assumptions about independence
that arise in physics.
So the first point is
we can just generalize
what Boltzmann was talking about.
And it arises in other cases
where physicists in statistical mechanics,
derive time-asymmetric
macroscopic dynamics,
using coarse-graining and so on.
I'm not going to go into
the details of that.
But a lot of these technical practices,
involve something much like what we saw
in Boltzmann H-theorem,
namely throwing away
correlations between subsystems
in order to just to derive
an asymmetric evolution.
You can also see this in an assumption
of no source-free radiation.
So this is often illustrated
using the example
of a stone thrown into a pond.
When we throw a stone in a pond,
we see the waves ripple out.
We very rarely see waves converge
and cause a stone to be
thrown out of the pond.
That kind of evolution
would require the same sort
of coherent evolution from the state
in order to have the kind of time reversal
of what we usually would expect to see.
And so there's another
condition that you can impose
that will rule out
exactly that kind of case.
And finally, I mean we could go on,
there's a lot of different cases
that illustrate this point,
here's a more subtle one.
It's actually quite,
there's a recent paper
by Williams, Miller and Dougherty
that analyzes something
that Weinberg introduced
as an axiom of QFT,
the cluster decomposition
principle as he called it.
So imagine you have clusters
of fields interacting
with one another
and then you take those to
be further and further away.
And the claim is that the
vacuum expectation values,
or the asymmetric elements
that you would use
to calculate things in
particle accelerators,
that those become independent
as you move those far away.
So again, it's a way of saying
that the probability
distribution factorizes
as a precise way of making
this independence claim.
And again, I think this
is the kind of thing
that you will find in a lot of
different aspects of physics,
independence assumptions of this sort.
So I think,
we can see the interventionist
approach to causation
as Woodward formulates it
as highlighting two very similar features
to what I've just introduced
in terms of the physics.
So these are more general statements
of the same kind of
independence that I've seen,
that I've been highlighting
as well-motivated physically.
So this is, the first is very close
to the Causal Markov Condition
that we saw in Thomas' talk yesterday.
I think this is actually
slightly weaker logically.
But if we have a bunch
of random variables,
if none are causes of other variables
and don't share a common cause,
then they should be
statistically independent.
So that's like the first
claim I was saying.
And the second, I don't
really like the name,
but I guess it's good enough,
value relationship independence.
This is related to the idea
that the way that the initial
variables are specified,
should be independent of the law,
or the causal generalization
that's relevant to them.
So these are exactly the
two features we saw earlier
in the case of the Boltzmann H-theorem.
So I think, let me just pause for a moment
and emphasize here.
So the point is I think these aspects
of the interventionist
program are actually good ways
of characterizing independence postulates
that play an essential
role in physics as well.
And so I see these as
sort of a generalization
from plausible physical principles
that seem to play an important role
in a variety of aspects of physics.
Now I think, a natural
response that you might've had
when I said I was going
to use an interventionist
approach to causation
and thinking about the
history of the deep past,
is to say, "Interventions?
Why are you talking about interventions?"
Right?
And this is just,
again, we saw this
yesterday in several talks,
a definition of cause
from an interventionist program requires
that it's in effect,
you're able to pick out and
directly intervene on a cause
that then has the intended effect.
And so the question here would be,
"Is it possible to control a variable Y
and only that variable
by acting on its cause?"
Right?
So can you locate a sort
of surgical intervention
in that kind of way?
Now the reason why this
might seem implausible,
is something we try to
apply to the deep past,
is what could we mean
by possible here, right?
So if you're doing an
experimental science,
you could try to do these directly
to assess the possibility.
Because you could determine
whether your causal graph,
is appropriately modeling
the data you're looking at
by trying the interventions
and seeing what happens.
But there's a basic question here
about how do we assess possibility?
And I think actually,
so this goes back to Woodward's book
from several years ago now,
I don't think we need to think possible
as just experimental manipulation.
There's a much broader
notion of possibility here.
And so as Woodward says,
he doesn't even think it has
to mean physically possible.
He has a little bit
further discussion here
about a strong sense of
physical possibility and so on.
But really the question is can
you define an intervention?
Can you actually specify an intervention
that would have the features
that we noted before?
And I think in a lot of cases,
we can actually think of
defining interventions
in a much looser way,
namely that we can think
of obviously an experimental context,
but we can think of natural experiments
where we think of the
environment as having an impact
on the system
where it will influence
a particular variable.
And so natural experiments
allow you to see
that you can have, if nature cooperates,
you can see the variation in that variable
as a result of the way
the system interacts
with the environment.
So you have in effect
implemented that manipulation
by looking at these separate systems.
And I think,
we also can assess these
questions of possibility
in some cases by doing simulations
where we can explore the possibility space
and see what's possible
in terms of varying, different variables.
So it's not really something
that is tied to human capabilities
in this definition of causation.
But I do think it's
really important to ask.
So all of these assessments
do involve some kind
of modal commitments.
So what's the way that
the system interacts
with the environment?
How do we think about possibility?
How's that enshrined in our simulations?
So I think we do want to say
that we can only use this
if our modal assessments,
at least have clear truth conditions,
so that we can determine
whether a particular
intervention is possible.
Now let me say,
if we think of our
anti-thermodynamics evolution
and we imagine the gas now
evolving away from equilibrium
and let's say we tried to
intervene on that system
in some way, right,
so that we would modify
its course of evolution,
here, I think when we
start to think about this,
we can see how hard it is to imagine
what an intervention would
look like in that case.
That's because we would,
anything we might try to do,
would disrupt the carefully
coordinated evolution
that's leading it away from equilibrium.
And so it seems like any
intervention is going to,
rather than changing,
let's say we want to change
something about the final state,
any intervention is going
to change everything
about the system, right?
And so this is a point made by Adam Elga
and then Porter Williams has
another recent discussion
of this.
So it's hard to see how you
could intervene in a system
that had that kind of evolution.
So that's a case where I'd say
if you're trying to intervene in a world
that had a failure of independence,
then it seems I have no understanding
of what interventions
would mean in that context.
But I think in other contexts,
we can say that we have an understanding
of the modal assessment necessary
to make these sorts of assessments.
So I think we can, for example,
going to the second point here,
we can give a modal assessment
of system-environment interactions,
sources of exogenous variation,
I think that's what people
in historical sciences are often doing
and have clear grounds for doing.
As we'll come back to right at the end,
I think it does get more tricky
if we're talking about
global properties of systems,
or global states or closed systems.
And so the other thing, as
I just emphasized before,
I think the interventionist
assumption of independence,
the feature that I think
is really interesting,
is that it depends not just on the laws,
but it also depends on
features of the initial state.
The initial state is uncorrelated
in an appropriate sense.
So that's a brief summary
of why I think the
interventionist approach,
brings out some features
of causal inference
that we can hopefully apply
to historical sciences.
And I want to now shift
to really briefly discuss
decoupling and traces.
So inferring causes from traces,
this is the standard kind of picture
that Thomas mentioned before as well,
that we see all kinds of cases
where we say there's an event,
such as a baseball going
through the window,
you have a lot of evidence,
the glass shards on the
floor, the baseball,
your child's cheapish look,
or if it was one of my daughters,
you'd just see them
running out of the door
(Christopher Smeenk giggles)
to avoid what was coming next.
But the traces then
overdetermine the cause.
That's the sort of line
that Carol Cleland gives
and I think there's something
that's right about it.
(audience member coughs)
But I think there's something
that is missing in these accounts,
which I think is actually really essential
for, at least, the historical
sciences that I've looked at,
which is that I think there are cases
that are quite a bit more powerful
than just inference from traces.
So Dave gave us a beautiful
discussion of the CMB yesterday.
So I deleted a bunch of slides.
(Christopher Smeenk laughs)
And the really crucial point
that I want to emphasize,
is that after about 380,000
years after the Big Bang,
the photons decouple
and they free-stream
essentially to our satellites
that are observing them or
our TVs if you have an old TV.
And through that evolution,
the photons themselves,
the average properties for the whole sky,
there's really no dynamical
process that is feasible
that would modify the average
temperature of the CMB,
other than the fact that due
to cosmological expansion,
the temperature is changing
with the scale factor.
So if you ask, "What is the mapping
from the current
observations of the CMB back
to the early universe?"
It's really a direct mapping.
So there are local variations,
which are quite important.
But you have a really direct mapping back
to the early state of the universe.
And so I think this seems
to me stronger than a trace.
And it's actually one thing
that Dave also emphasized,
but I think is worth saying once more,
the CMB has driven cosmology
for the last 50 years.
So it's enabled precision
cosmology in a way
that other observations
are now catching up to.
But the level of precision
that's available in
observations of the CMB
and the fact that we've
kept coming back for more,
there's more and more features of the CMB
that have been revealing further details
about the early universe
that are very rich and important
and constraining and understanding
cosmological theories.
So I think it's a bit
stronger than just a trace.
And so this is a group in 1957 at MIT,
who are confident that this time capsule
that they're installing,
I don't know where it is on campus,
would be dug up in 2957.
So they expect it to last for a millennia.
So that's a good, optimistic take.
And I think that a lot of systems
that people use in historical
sciences are time capsules
in roughly the sense of this
sort of everyday time capsule.
Namely it's a quasi-isolated system
that evolves according to its
own dynamics in some sense,
like the CMB,
there's an autonomous dynamics
that governs the temperature.
And it's quasi-isolated
in the sense that there are
very few dynamical interactions
that will disturb the
state of the time capsule.
Obviously, this is defeasible,
like it's something that
you can have failures
of that sort of isolation.
But there are a lot of cases
where the time capsules also
give you further information,
such as a internal clock
that allows you to not just say infer
what the state of a system was earlier,
but infer something
about the time elapsed,
since it decoupled from the environment.
And so this is actually a really
rich source of information
and I have one example
that is something that you
might not have heard of before.
So isotopic ratios are
a good time capsule,
because there's very few things
that change the isotopic ratios
for radioactive elements.
And so this is a mine in Gabon
that in the early seventies,
people discovered something quite unusual
and this was the Cold War era.
The amount of uranium-235
compared to uranium-238 was wrong.
And so they thought maybe there was some,
maybe the Soviets had
been doing something,
maybe there was some kind of
nuclear activity taking place.
And it turns out there
was nuclear activity,
but it was actually naturally
occurring nuclear reactors.
So because of the low
uranium-235 abundances,
they did some reconstructions.
And so this is a map that shows,
and the black spots,
are where naturally occurring
fission reactors took place
about 1.7 billion years ago.
And so what this illustrates
is that there's a time capsule
that the isotopic ratios are so secure
that you're able to discover,
like what could possibly have
changed those isotopic ratios?
It's essentially only a fission reaction.
And then they're able to reconstruct
how could a fission
reaction have taken place.
It has to do with the groundwater.
1.7 billion years ago,
there was more U-235 present
and then they could confirm that
by looking at other kind of decay products
of the interaction.
And they could see also
from the shape of the rock
that it had been heated
up quite significantly.
So that's just an example
of how the departure
from this quasi-isolate dynamics,
is also incredibly revealing.
Now I've used examples from physics,
just because that's what I know.
But I would expect that there
are similar kinds of systems
in biology and evolutionary biology
where you can think of them
as something more like a time capsule
that gives you a very secure
way of inferring earlier states
of the system of interest.
Okay, so what does the
world have to be like
to enable reconstructions
of the deep past?
Well, I focus first on
worldly infrastructure.
Now in terms of traces and time capsules,
really, it's very similar to a theme
that has come up in a
few of the talks before
that what is important here,
is a kind of dynamical
decoupling of systems
from their environment,
so that they evolve independently
and they can be treated
as isolated systems.
And that's something we've seen
in other contexts in physics
where people have been using
effective field theories,
very well
where you have a kind of scale separation
that allows you to treat
these as separable.
Now obviously this is going to be,
I don't know that I can say
much more generally about this,
it's gonna be very
background-theory-dependent,
being able to find a time capsule,
figuring out how to use it.
But I think our world does provide us
with some of these time capsules
and very persistent and revealing traces.
Okay, so the very last brief comment
on early universe cosmology.
So I mentioned before,
I think that there are some
issues regarding cosmology.
But I first wanna say,
I think this is a very
limited part of cosmology
that poses particular problems.
So I think in a lot of cases in cosmology,
we actually can try to
make the modal assessment
of whether something is
a possible intervention
by the same ways that
we do in other contexts,
so either through natural experiments,
looking at a large
sample of similar systems
and seeing how some features vary
across the different
elements of that ensemble,
or exploring possibility
spaces through simulations
where we have a lot large
confidence in the theories
that we're using to
construct those simulations.
So I think for a lot of
questions in cosmology,
we can answer these
interventionist questions,
perfectly well.
I think in some cases though,
and in particular in the early universe,
this is more of an n-equals-one problem
as Dave emphasized last time.
Because we don't have
any other realizations
and then we face the difficulty
of drawing a contrast
between law-like and contingent features.
And furthermore, the
theory that's developed
to render an observed history plausible
to make it the case
that what we see is to be expected,
given our understanding of the dynamics,
is also really only tested
through those same observations
and the ability to reconstruct history.
So there's a kind of worry
about a circularity there
that I think is really hard to get around.
So I think in that case,
it's not clear that the
interventionist approach helps
in addressing that problem,
just because we face the problem
of not really understanding modalities
as clearly as we do in other contexts.
Okay, so just to summarize then,
"What does the world have to be like
to enable reliable reconstructions?"
So I've argued that the
kinds of assumptions
that are needed to be in place
for an interventionist causal analysis,
also have to be in place here,
that we need independence assumptions
and then also to
understand the modal status
of interventions.
And also that I think there's
more interesting kinds
of traces,
which I've called time capsules
that really do provide
a lot of information.
And what seems to be the general feature
that allows for those to exist,
is a decoupling of systems
that makes it possible
for those to be treated
as effectively isolated.
So thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- [Moderator 1] Thank you much
Chris for keeping with time.
- Questions?
Eduardo.
- [Eduardo] Thank you, Chris,
very, very interesting talk.
I just wanna hear your thoughts.
You were telling us
how you feel comfortable
moving some data in cosmology
from maybe traces to something
that you would call
evidence or observation.
And I wonder why do we need,
I mean, I was just pulling up
and I say that most of you probably know,
because it's by Carl Sagan
on "The Burden of Skepticism"
that I give to the students
all the time, right?
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Eduardo] Why do we need to do that,
unless what we're trying to do is to move
from just taking the result's face value
to making decisions that are contingent
on whether we're gonna
consider it a trace,
or a confirm fact?
And he was thinking,
it (indistinct) made me think
about how I would like
science or society to operate
with the same kind of data
if you're discussing father
and certainty in our monkeys-
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Eduardo] Or you have a
human being in a court of law,
who may go to jail for my
assessments of paternity?
It could be the same
numbers, the same data,
but we may still decide
to call one not enough
to make onto moving the decision.
- Hmm.
- [Eduardo] And the other
one I can live with making,
I mean, I allow myself to call this a fact
if I'm discussing all monkeys
in a workshop at Yale.
- Hmm.
- [Eduardo] But I may decide,
"I'm gonna keep calling it a trace.
Because I do not want to
pass judgment on somebody,
who may or may not be the
father of this young."
So I think again, it takes
us going back and forth
between the actual results.
- Hmm.
- [Eduardo] And our assumption
that we're gonna use
that for something else.
- Right, no, I think
this is a general feature
that epistemic standards
that are appropriate to
different contexts shift, right?
And I think cosmology,
there aren't as many decision contexts
where it really matters
if you've got the right value
of the Hubble constant, right?
So I think there's different ways
of asking the decision question though,
which I think, if you're
going to take something
as giving you insight
into the causal structure
of how the universe evolved,
I think that gives you a much richer sense
of the further consequences of that.
And so some of,
this is a slightly different question,
you're asking more,
like "How should we classify
something as a trace,
or how confident should we be
in thinking of it as a time capsule?"
There's also then if you
use it in a certain way,
you might get a better picture
of like here's the causal structure.
And then that might have
further implications
for other aspects of
cosmological modeling, right?
So I think in cosmology,
just because it's intrinsically,
incredibly valuable field,
but not something that has
like direct extrinsic impact
on day-to-day decisions for the most part,
I think that's gonna be the impact.
It's more on the implications
for other aspects
of cosmological modeling.
And then yeah, I think your
degree of confidence can shift.
Like if it's something
that you think is an essential
feature of your modeling
and you're gonna build
like 20 years worth of research on this,
you'd probably have a,
or I think a different way this comes up,
is like motivating large-scale,
very expensive telescopes.
You wanna have a lot of confidence
that what you're looking
for is really something
that's going to be very decisive
in answering the question
you're interested in.
And so you might then have
a very careful analysis
of like how certain are we
about this as a source of-
- It's when we want to make decisions
about public money investment,
right, for example.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, Alex?
- Thanks.
I wanted to just ask a bit more
about the focus on the deep
past as opposed to recent past.
- [Christopher Smeenk] Right.
- Because it seemed like this question
of kind of what's the scope and limits
of our knowledge about the deep past?
You could also ask it
about the recent past
and you were saying that
current or recent things,
we can like perform experiments
in a way that we can't
directly perform experiments
about the deep past.
But on the other hand,
it is still true
that in order to be able
to trust our memories
of the recent past,
we're relying on assumptions
about there aren't a lot
of anti-thermodynamic things happening.
So I was wondering like
the conditions you listed,
would you also think them
to be basically necessary
for knowledge of the recent past?
And if so, then how do you see
the focus on the deep past?
What's the importance of that focus,
as opposed to just focus
on the past in general?
- Yeah, no, so there's a lot of the story
that I think would be roughly
the same for the recent past.
So you have to have an account of memory,
you have to have an account of how it is
that you form records or take
certain things as records.
And I think that doesn't
really discriminate
between the deep past and recent past.
So a lot of what I say, I
think just does carry over.
But I think partly,
it's within the context
of the recent discussions
of historical sciences
that people are stating
these kinds of pessimism
that do depend on the
amount of time-lapse.
So even so I think for
some of the skeptics,
even if you imagine
that "If my daughter broke
the window yesterday,
I could find the traces,"
if that's the way you think
of the evidences working
and you think that those
traces decay over time,
then you have a reason for thinking
that the account of the recent past,
just won't extend that far.
And part of what I'm arguing,
is actually if you have
something like a time capsule,
that actually can be stable
over 13.8 billion years, right?
(Christopher Smeenk giggles)
So I think that some of what I'm saying,
is that there's some systems
that allow you to extend
much more straightforwardly
into the deep past.
And I think that just hasn't
been fully recognized in this-
- [Moderator 2] The
reliability of the evidence,
right, basically-
- Yeah.
- [Moderator 2] Can be quite different.
So in the interest of
not keeping everyone away
from lunch too long,
let's thank Chris and move on
to our final pre-lunch talk.